Hello there.
Now I know what you're
thinking.
Crikey, a black cat!
He's gonna bring me bad luck.
Shows what you know about luck.
♪♪
Let's drop some knowledge.
Luck is different all around the
world.
Like in Scotland... where a
black cat like me is considered
very lucky.
Remember kids, don't try this at
home.
Names Bob, by the way.
And this is the land of luck.
Morning, Gerry.
We work behind the scenes to
create those
wee lucky and unlucky moments
that make up your every day
life.
Like these guys, an entire team
thinking up the jammie work.
That kinda makes you feel like
a million bucks.
(Cheering)
Okay, maybe a hundred bucks.
Of course then there's the other
team.
Working on the not so jammie
kind of luck.
And they sure love what they do.
Well, you humans are a
complicated lot.
And that's why things run so
smoothly here.
Because no human has ever
stepped foot in this place.
And with a little bit luck, they
never will.
(Bang)
Oww!
(Crash sounds)
Uh, where am I?
Oh, you got to be kidding.
♪♪
(Chuckles)
(Sigh)
Hmm.